all right all right that's too loud hey
so guys my name is trono I'm here in
Sweden with Peter my employee so what
better way to spend a beautiful sunset
about 500 kilometers north of
Stockholm
then by answering your beautiful
questions so I put out a little q a on
Instagram and YouTube just about hazel
because Peter's primary job here at
Studio channel is Hazel he actually
works on Hazel more than I do because
I'm busy making videos like this one
yeah okay so I guess we can start with
something that's kind of on topic to
where we are at the moment uh how's
Sweden I've heard that it's a great
place that's a stupid question I was
gonna just answer the house Sweden part
of it but then I'm like it's a great
place what am I going to say how sweet
and good okay so in no particular order
I'm gonna just browse through Instagram
Peter's got a YouTube open as well with
the questions and we're just going to
answer whatever questions we get just
gonna turn that sound off yes so this
question how do you guys keep everything
organized or you don't
I think that's a good question
um are you talking more about like the
production side of things or the actual
code
you know how clean like the card is
because I think production Wise It's
like jira helps a lot with that yeah
yeah so we use like a number of I guess
organizational tools
um I guess I kind of fulfill the role of
development director producer as well as
technical director so I lead kind of
both the technical development of Hazel
but then obviously like we don't have a
dedicated person you usually have
someone that's just in charge of running
the show making sure that everyone is
kind of working together as a team
um rather than just like you know
everyone doing their own stuff like work
needs to be tracked some way and there
pretty much always has to be someone
kind of in charge of leading the actual
development so that we can deliver you
know goals on time and fulfill kind of
our targets so that's kind of my job as
well
um I do a pretty bad job at that I
actually mentioned this in the video
which I guess I'll have links up
wherever
um where I talked about like the tools
that we use to you know manage Hazel
yeah I talked about how much of a bad
job I'm doing at that because it's
difficult to not have like a dedicated
person to kind of do that but jira helps
a lot definitely being able to kind of
you know use the I guess road map view
and just see at a glance like if we have
a Target like hazel 2023.2 which is our
next release like what what exactly
needs to be done for that who is working
on what and what are their expected like
estimated time levels so that we can
like make sure that we hit that you know
on time or at least at a certain time
which helps a lot yeah what do you think
like in terms of code organization I
mean I think in terms of code it's
usually like pretty relaxed it's like up
to each and every one to kind of
organize their code themselves but then
we have you know certain guidelines like
if you need to change code that isn't
yours you need to talk to the person who
owns that code yeah which I think is
really good yeah we have like a bit of a
code etiquette guide on docs.hazal
engine.com which actually anyone can
access yeah I think it's been since
since we added that it's been pretty
good I think yeah what part of the
engine do you feel requires the most
amount of work slash maintenance either
due to missing features or reworking
existing ones like API redesigns you
know what I'm gonna say just the editor
yeah like we don't have an undo or redo
system even though like that is planned
but that's been planned for a while yeah
and it's just surprisingly one of those
features that you don't really need as
much as you think you need but of course
it's nice to have yeah so in terms of
like missing features like you know
because we've shipped like three games
that we've made in game jams and like
they they are I guess what you would
call feature complete for a game yeah
right like they have a launcher with a
graphic settings that's where your
journey kind of starts and then like the
game itself like it's a 3D game with
various kind of different tiers of
Graphics quality that you can set
uh it's got audio it's got c-sharp
scripting for like gameplay and behavior
like obviously we load a number of
different assets and it kind of looks
and feels like a game yeah you know and
we have asset packaging and it's it's a
multi-threaded runtime like I feel like
that's like kind of almost the base
requirements for like you know can you
ship a game with this game engine does
it have all the features that would kind
of make a a game feel like a game
and I think we check pretty much all the
boxes but as far as develop developing
that game goes like I feel like the
editor is probably the longest list of
features you know because like games are
so subjective as well like what are you
gonna do you're going to be like oh yeah
we don't have Global illumination for
graphics but do you need that to make a
game well it depends what game you want
to make yeah so
yeah I'd say for me honestly it's just a
scripting engine and that's mostly in
terms of like redesigning and also just
like with all the games we've made the
scripting engine has really just been
the the system that's been the most
trouble so because it's always required
some hacky work around to get some very
specific thing to work and
I'm gonna blame that partially on mono
but it it's also like you know obviously
on me seeing as I wrote it
um and I I haven't been happy with it
pretty much since I wrote it
um so
yeah I'd say it's definitely scripting
for me yeah although the editor is very
kind of
lacking of features I guess what part of
the Hazel engine has been the most fun
to work on
you can go first oh uh physics easily I
love physics it's incredible to work on
it's I think physics is a good one
because it's so deep but yeah I guess
it's kind of like rendering in a way
like rendering like there's so many
different techniques and so many
different styles yeah and it's kind of
like physics like you think you've got
it all but then there's stuff like
um soft bodies yeah or like buoyancy or
you know like material and cloth and
stuff yeah definitely and like physics
is
just so fun to me partially because like
that's the first thing I worked on in
Hazel and so it's like very close to my
heart with that but also it's just like
you can keep working on physics pretty
much forever and you still won't get
everything in and things will constantly
keep changing
and it's just
I think it's very much because it's like
very visual
like you make a tiny change and that can
have a significant effect to what it
looks like yeah and I think that's just
really interesting I think physics is
more I mean I think most people probably
agree with me it's probably more
important than rendering because like I
mean you know you need some rendering
but the thing is like physics really
makes the game feel like a game yeah you
know if you you could have really
simplistic graphics
but if you just add like some physics
and Bulls like rolling around and
colliding and like destruction and all
of this other stuff like it immediately
makes it feel like so much better and
not to mention that like you know you
need physics because stuff has to
collide into other things and yeah you
know even something like you know the
first Mario game you know what is that
Super Mario Brothers you know like that
game it's so simple but like you know of
course there's physics everywhere like
with how Mario moves and accelerates and
jumps and like how high he jumps and
like hitting blocks and stuff like yeah
it's it's so important and also physics
is I think the only engine system
that you that I have had zero part in
yeah because like with scripting I wrote
the first kind of ripping thing I had
seashell scripts working and then you
came along and actually made that into
like a extensible usable system that we
could have yeah but with physics like I
we had zero physics in Hazel when you
just came in and that was your first
real contact with me yeah and you were
just like hey here's a like I added 3D
physics to Hazel using Nvidia physics
like here it is yeah and of course the
initial implementation was garbage but
it became better better than zero yeah
not having anything yeah
so that was that's an important kind of
yeah that's a very important development
milestone in Hazel's history definitely
I think it's interesting because when
you look at a lot of like
popular games like not even Triple A
games but just Indie Games most of like
a lot of them are just effective here uh
glorified physics simulations like you
have a BeamNG Drive which is literally
just crash physics
um tear down is yeah you know
artistically well graphically I should
say
simple although you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of topics
definitely yeah but like in terms of the
overall art style lights well yeah
they're not like uh you know it doesn't
have a huge a huge like art asset
exactly and scarp yeah and like the
reason why that's a good game is just
because
there's the whole destruction of the
environment and all that kind of physics
interactions is just so much fun to go
in with yeah all right let's just do a
simple one will Hazel have any kind of
JavaScript support in it
you know if we if we do expand a little
bit on the topic of what languages like
hazel support like uh like C sharp it
really begins and ends with C sharp like
yeah I have zero plans to add anything
else like C plus plus is kind of just
works out of the box because if you have
Hazel you have access obviously to
Hazel's like source code which is
written in C plus plus so it's very very
easy for you to just come in and add a c
plus function you know that you can then
call from C sharp if you want to write
code in C plus yeah um and of course
because you have all the Engine Systems
there if you want to modify or extend an
existing engine system you can also
really easily do that you can add your
own kind of components to the game
engine from within C plus plus and do
whatever work workload you kind of want
there and tie it to C sharp however you
want so I think that kind of C plus plus
and C sharp that kind of Synergy that
those languages have I really like
personally yeah and I think that that's
like you know when we when we eventually
move on to developing an actual game
like I truly believe that's
all we need in terms of like the tools
to make game scripting happen
you know it's going to be cboss wasn't C
sharp mix and match like whatever makes
the most sense and you're kind of done
like I don't think you need visual
scripting I don't think you need like
some weirdo custom scripting language
tedious Crypt yeah I don't think you
need any of that like yeah C sharp is a
very uh established very elegant very
popular language that most people agree
is just a really good language yeah and
I I think that there's just very little
need for more than one scripting
language in any engine really it's like
I think it just makes it just makes it
explodes it yeah it just makes things
inconsistent and like what do you choose
it's like if you have a huge menu to
choose from at a restaurant like I
honestly I hate that it's like what do
you what do you pick I'm saying in all
these hotels in Sweden which just have
buffet breakfast and I'm like the heck
this sucks I'm gonna eat like 10 times
as much as I usually what I want to try
everything yeah just give me a give me a
meal on a plate and I'm good to go you
know I think C sharp is a really good
choice for a scripting language because
it has really well established uh
establish published intro with C plus I
don't know I think that like the primary
reason why I because I did consider
JavaScript very briefly I considered Lua
Python and JavaScript yeah uh well NC
shop and I ended with c-sharp because I
knew that eventually I would want to
make like a decently large scoped game
in Hazel and I asked myself like okay if
I have to write something complicated
like you know a 10 000 plus lines of
code let's just say probably more like
20 30 000 lines of code like and we you
know a full-on game like would I want to
do that in lure
and it was like no yeah like would I
want to do this in Python like I mean
you could but like it's dynamically
typed it's like it just feels it just
it's slower as well like that's a
consideration yeah like you know
JavaScript like I'm just not I'm not as
used to it and like of course you can
write complex stuff in JavaScript but
you know at the end of the day like you
know it comes down to being a personal
decision as well and it was like okay
we'll see Sharp very fast really good
Library very it's a c like language
right it's strongly typed like it kind
of just checks all the boxes really yeah
and like of course you can write slow C
sharp code but you you know I think it's
with C sharp it's more it's harder to
write it's really slow code yeah than it
is to write fast code because usually
we're like the performance bottlenecks
come from is when you
try to simplify The Code by using
effectively syntax sugar yeah like using
the link libraries and using those kinds
of functions they're slow like yeah sure
they're
you know easy to read sometimes
but you're gonna lose a lot of
performance with it and so you might as
well just not use them all right next
question what is the main motive for
starting Hazel if I recall correctly you
were at EA back then was it some kind of
Escape
um that's a good question like I think
the motive behind Hazel like that
probably should be its own video really
because I think that surprisingly it
goes as far back as my childhood like
not specifically game engines but the
fact that like
you know I I would always kind of
whatever I saw someone else kind of do
or whatever I
I guess especially media related that I
saw I really wanted to be able to do
that myself you know whether it was like
make a movie make games like you know
that they would very quickly come a time
when I'd be consuming media and I would
really want to stop and start creating
media yeah right and so like I think
you know because I was also kind of into
technical stuff and I liked math and I I
it kind of naturally fell into place
that like yeah I like media and I like
movies and stuff but you know it's
almost like a game is like a movie plus
math you know it's like a movie with
some interaction
um and so that really drew me in and
then of course I wanted to do it kind of
myself and from scratch and how do you
make a game from scratch like you know
well you could just make the game from
scratch but these days because the games
are so complex you have to build tools
that enable you to make those games and
those tools are called game engines and
so I think that's why like I mean really
as far back as I can remember I guess
that path was almost just present you
know it would eventually fall into that
path yeah and then it was just only a
matter of time like I got a job
obviously working I didn't apply at EA
to work on game engines like that's not
how that happened I thought I was going
to be on a game team but then the studio
technical director saw my resume and
pulled me onto his team and he was in
charge of the game engine and so that
was great because I liked game man
transporting games anyway but that's
kind of how that happened and then
eventually I was like this is too
complicated like frostbite is too big I
have too small of a part in this like I
want to make my own thing and so I left
and that's the motivation behind Hazel
it was
purely I guess looking at my life and
being like what do I want to do with my
life what do I like doing like who cares
about the money like what do I want to
do I want to make a game engine and then
I think after that it was obviously
working out well can I make a living off
of this yeah can I support my family and
um you know
it worked out so that's kind of the
motivation of the journey yeah
now you're sitting in a field in the
middle of nowhere did not yeah did not
see this one coming this is actually
Peter's fault if he never wrote that
physics engine I wouldn't be here you
know what that's I can't argue with that
is Hazel a good way for a beginner to
make some games
um yes and no I think that it's
Simplicity like the problem at the
moment with hazel I think is the
educational content surrounding how you
how it can be used yeah like uh you know
we really we have some plans for the
future and we really would like to make
hazel more publicly accessible and
um you know just an actual kind of
platform and a tool that you can use to
build games and I think when that rolls
around we'll have more content you know
in the form of like tutorials and stuff
that would teach you how to use it and
that's obviously very important but I
think that if that were to exist then I
feel like it would be better for a
beginner to use it because a like hazel
works really well out of the box like
you don't need to tweak graphic settings
to make your shadows look good yeah you
don't need to like wait an hour for
packages to like oh what packages do you
want to use for this or like do you want
to use this rent a pipeline no you just
open Hazel it opens in I don't know a
few seconds right especially if you use
Shader packs in the editor by the way
which we don't that's why we're used to
slightly longer load times yeah but
anyway it opens in a few seconds you've
already got a new project you can just
make a new scene instantly you just
start making a game you can hit play
hitting plays like that you know
everything's just so blazingly fast and
partly that's because it's so simple and
I guess the thing is like if you're a
beginner well you want simple right yeah
you're not going to get into every
single deep feature
um and so like yeah I mean I guess I
honestly strongly believe that Hazel
would be an amazing place for a beginner
to kind of start making games because
it's going to I feel like there's going
to be less frustrations less kind of
just waiting for stuff or not knowing
which button to press because if you've
only got It's Like The Menu restaurant
menu thing if you've only got five
buttons to press you can't really stray
too far you know but if you're in such a
complex engine you know then like what
are you going to do an Unreal Engine
accidentally stumble into like cinematic
tools and suddenly you're making the
Mandalorian yeah like
you know so
um it's been about a week on the
animation system you know just like
trying to learn yeah how to do the
simplest animations yeah like there are
there are serious benefits to Simplicity
yeah you know like so much stuff these
days is complicated and people think
that they want the engine with the most
features but like if at the end of the
day like for I feel like for most games
that people want to make like you really
don't need as much as you think and that
limitation almost forces you to be more
creative hey here's something that I
actually want to mention yeah so I have
a
I have a 19 month old daughter so I'm of
course into babies now
and one of the things that I read
recently is that babies have higher
quality play time if you give them less
toys
so if you put them into like a little
play area and you give them less toys
the babies that get that they have
higher quality Play Time meaning that
like with those few toys they use them
in more ways and the end result is they
actually play for longer they stay in
that play area without crying and
wanting like to get back to their
parents and wanting attention they stay
there for longer so less toys higher
quality play time more different ways
those toys are used in and they actually
end up spending more time there than if
they had more toys to choose from
because that's almost counterintuitive
you think that like if you give them
more toys well they'll just slowly
progress from one to the other but no so
that's really really fascinating and
I'll I'll try and Link that paper or
whatever whatever article I read
um like Below in case anyone's
interested but like that I think that's
fascinating and like I feel like you
know there's a real benefit to limiting
yourself because it's almost like it
forces you to be more of a human and use
your imagination and kind of you know
like like people say less is more yeah
so that's like maybe that should be our
our slogan Hazel less is more yeah yeah
I mean I guess like in a way it makes
sense with the whole like toy thing
because the fact that they have less
toys I feel like would encourage them to
be more creative in how they use yeah
I had I I had I didn't have that many
toys as a kid like maybe as a baby I did
I don't remember but like I remember
like very uh clearly that like you like
I I would never get toys like new toys
just like that like it would usually be
for my birthday or like for Christmas
and so like I still remember there was a
single moment when I came home from
school I was probably like 10 and there
were just there was just a new toy on my
bed and I that that was so memorable
because stuff like that never happened
and I feel like that really forced me to
yeah be more creative to use my
imagination more and pretend I was doing
that or I was this or whatever because
like you know when you when you kind of
have less
like you I don't know like that's also
why I guess spoiling kids is a bad idea
and I knew so many more people now I'm
probably gonna cut this time so yeah
like it's super interesting yeah I think
another interesting thing an interesting
thought is like I mean what makes
a game engine unique you know like it's
kind of like when when people make games
why is this game different from another
game because people love asking the
question of like oh but why are you
making a game engine like how is it
different to something else yeah and
it's like well you could also ask that
about a game right like why are you
making a game how is this game different
like oh you're making a first person
shooter how is it different to like Call
of Duty or Counter-Strike or Battlefield
or you know whatever right like and I
feel like most people there would be
like oh well let's art though like the
art has been made from scratch yeah yeah
but like our code and our UI and all of
that stuff has been made from scratch
yeah you know and it's like oh well you
use jolt you're using existing stuff
yeah well you use the game engine to
make a game you know like I don't really
think that there's there's really a
difference and I mean that could go into
a different video which is like why are
we making a game engine yeah but yeah I
like to make a video like that annually
basically yeah because yeah I've seen a
few of those yeah but yeah no like for
me
I I wanted to make game engines because
I first of all wanted to make games
realized actually I find the core
technology more interesting
um and I wanted to learn more about that
and now it's just become more of a
honestly like for me making a game
engine is part of making some kind of
art because even though it's not like a
game of traditional art
it's still a very creative process yeah
so it is you know it to me it's like
asking okay well why are you making this
painting when Leonardo da Vinci already
made the Mona Lisa
yeah I think that like it's it's very
creative on a technical level you know
like some people like visual art and
obviously like they they're just yeah
painting like photography that's like
their medium but then
a lot of people they also really like
you know math and like technical stuff
and code and programming and so it's
like I feel like making a game engine is
really cool because it's like it's a
platform that you're making that is just
a whole bunch of whatever technology you
can really think of jammed into one
package yeah you know and that's a
really cool way for someone who
you know wants to be creative but on a
on a technical level to you know Express
that creativity yeah like I've never
been good at traditional art like
painting more
uh graphic design or anything like that
and so for me it's it's fun because I
get to be creative but I get to be
creative in a very kind of
specific space that's
more Technical and logical than you know
traditional art
yeah
all right wrap it up there thank you
guys for your questions uh we might do
another one of these in the future
although maybe not together because I'm
leaving tomorrow yeah but um thank you
guys for watching don't forget to hit
the like button patreon.com is where you
can get access to Hazel and yeah thanks
for your support I'll see you later if
you want to do the outro form thing I
can do it yeah
um I guess yeah bye